alors qu'à meldhau d'abord le personnage
principal de votre précédent roman se
demande s'il doit écrire ou se taire
vous avez vite choisi aujourd'hui on
vous appelle l'homme révolté qui ne peut
pas se taire alors établissent un lien
direct entre la misère sexuelle et la
montée du radicalisme religieux
vous dites tant que les religieux auront
le monopole du discours sur le sexe nous
ne guériront pas c'est ce que je pense
d'abord dans les sociétés dites arabe et
même ici il faut qu'on arrache le
discours sur la sexualité et la mort au
religieux je ne comprends pas pourquoi
religion a le droit de discourir sur la
sexualité tout le temps de l'épilation à
la hauteur du talon et dès qu'un
intellectuel le fait on l'accuse
d'essentialisme en accuse de trahison de
sa propre communauté vit en fait
l'érotisme est une clé de ma vision du
monde c'est revenir à l'essentiel avant
toute chose on est désiré et désirable
si on perd les deux on perd tout donc
pour moi l'érotisme ce n'est pas
exclusivement l'expression sexuelle ça
va au delà se parle de misère sexuelle
mais je parle aussi de misère culturelle
quand on n'a pas accès un bal et un
théâtre à une piscine un livre à une
salle de cinéma on est dans une misère
perotti compères le lien de désirons il
est désirable il avait du monde et ça
c'est important alors le rapport à la
femme est pour vous finalement une sorte
de baromètre des civilisations c'est ce
que je vous jalousez c'est vous malgré
tout je n'idéalise pas outre mesure et
l'occident je ne suis pas naïf et en
même temps je me dis c'est une c'est
quelque chose que j'ai conclu un jour
j'étais en suisse en suisse italienne on
est sorti le soir après un festival et
j'ai vu des femmes se promener et je me
suis dit c'est leur seule avance sur
nous c'est la liberté des femmes qu'on
ne veuille pas avec toute mesure garder
guy
leur gaz n'est pas une traîtrise il
n'est pas un concept de l'occident c'est
un droit universel c'est très simple
lorsqu'on est un intellectuel au entre
entre deux passions et de culture entre
une heure et une culture que l'on
regarde de loin entre l'occident et le
maghreb on est toujours soir en fabrique
de vous le dissident en occident parce
que l'occident est fabriqué des
dissidents soit enfin avec de vous le
traître de l'autre côté le casting est
très simple ce qui représente
l'authenticité l'identité la spécificité
culturelle sont devenus les religieux et
les conservateurs et les populistes et
nous qui défendons des valeurs
universelles non seulement de soutien
occidental comme l'orgasme comme la la
liberté le droit du buisson au corps on
est assimilé à des agents de l'occident
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
très stricte permanente alors le 13
décembre 2014 dans on n'est pas couché
vous dit que la religion est un frein au
développement du monde arabe une fatwa
est lancé contre vous un imam salafiste
réclame votre mort pour apostasie
hérésie sur facebook il ya eu combien de
like comme ça il faut lui demander à lui
non mais estime que me mettre en avant
par rapport à d'autres qui souffrent
dans cette géographie là c'est indécent
je pense qu'une lycéenne kidnappé à par
boko haram a plus de légitimité que moi
de parler un petit peu de martyrs de
souffrance et de menaces mais en même
temps on est dans une situation où
lorsqu'on défend son avis on est
toujours toujours attaquer est ce que je
disais à l'époque c'est que je pense que
les gens ont le droit de choisir un dieu
mais ils n'ont pas à l'imposer aux
autres et donc c'est ce que dit mon père
sont désormais reçoit ou la religion
c'est un transport connaître collectif
que je ne prends pas donc il est
chercher chercher un lieu phare l'avoir
trouvée l'adoré en faire le centre de
service est tout à fait légitime je me
bats pour que les gens puissent avoir
cette liberté là mais en même temps je
me bats pour que ce qui là ils ont
trouvé ne lasse ne la pose pas aux
autres on est bien d'accord alors le 31
janvier 2016 vous publier une tribune
dans le monde au sujet des agressions
sexuelles à la gare de cologne pour le
nouvel an vous dites que les immigrés
ont échappé à leur géographie mais c'est
pas parce qu'ils viennent ici qu'ils
échappent à leur culture non c'est un
appel on vient d'abord dans c'est une
tribune qui a été publié en italie
reprise en allemagne en angleterre en
suisse elle n'a pas provoqué autant de
bruit mais publie en france et l
explosion sont dit aussi beaucoup sur
votre pays et sur comment perçois les
choses et sur les dénis qu'on entretient
dans votre pays donc ce qui se disait
c'est un texte en deux parties je disais
que d'un côté ceux qui ferment les
portes c'est vous serons obligé un jour
de tirer par les fenêtres il faut
l'assumer et se défend l'idée d'une
solidarité universelle mais d'un autre
côté être dans l'angélisme et accueillir
et croire être absous du reste n'est pas
vrai parce que je ne comprends pas que
quelqu'un puisse échapper un pays en
guerre pour chercher la liberté mais que
cette liberté de la veut pour lui pas
pour sa femme qui est fait qui marche
derrière donc il faut participer à la
liberté que l'on cherche et il faut la
défendre pour tout cela qu'on appelait
alors
trois jours après cette colonne donc
dans des journaux européens
un groupe d'intellectuels français vous
taxent d'anti humanisme d'islamophobie
est ce une shop vous songé à arrêter vos
chroniques parce que se faire allumer
par les islamistes c'est une chose mais
se faire allumer par des intellectuels
français
c'est quand même très grave c'était la
goutte qui faisait dix ont débordé le
vase j'ai subi en même temps c'est un
caprice de riche le succès de meursault
contre enquête qui était énorme je
m'attendais absolument pas ma parole de
v devenez un peu plus surveillés donc il
était devenu un médiatique alors pas
hésité avant un journaliste ils étaient
entre deux mondes entre deux cultures et
je perdais contrôle sur ma propre parole
donc je voulais revenir à ma passion est
essentielle qui était la littérature
qu'il y ait des réactions ici les gens
sont libres de dire ce qu'ils veulent
mais moi je vis là bas et d'un autre
côté qu'on m'accuse de ne pas pouvoir et
de ne pas avoir le droit de parler de
mon réel au nom d'une sorte de rente
post coloniale au nom d'un corps autant
de crédits universitaires ça je le
refuse on est en train de réinventer le
politiquement correct de le radicaliser
quelque part le post coloniale et une
ronde d'une rente universitaire et une
ronde victime heures et une rente de
confort sa jeunesse ou pas la
colonisation mais je dis qu'il faut
qu'on sait qu'on s'en sorte il faut
qu'on parle du présent 62 exactement et
donc j'ai refuse que je sois
l'illustration d'une discours colonial
où je joue la victime et qui se tait je
parle de montréal et de mon présent est
maintenant et je parle comme je veux
vous a traité effectivement
d'islamophobe de collabo de harkis des
sionistes d'apostats de traîtres
d'agents de l'occident qu'elle et les
insultes qui vous a fait le plus mal
quand même ce n'est pas un incident qui
me vise c'est une insulte qui vise les
miens c'est ce qui fait le plus mal
parce que moi je suis peut-être plus ou
moins la facture peut être avec
vandalisent avec les granités mais quand
ça touche les miens cela me blesse et
puis je n'aime pas qu'on doute de ma
bonne foi je suis quelqu'un qui essaie
de trouver des réponses qui fait c'est
de construire des réponses je n'aime pas
qu'on dise que je fais ça pour avoir des
papiers en occident ouais je n'aime pas
qu'on dise que je fais ça pour vous
plaire à vous occidentaux parce que de
toute manière moi je ne veux pas être
vous je veux être mieux que vous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu